j'accueille vahina giocante
damien alors vahina giocante dans vahina
ça veut dire bienvenue en malgache parce
que vous avez passé les premières années
de votre vie en afrique
votre père était dans le business des
pierres précieuses des émeraudes et joe
dante alors ça vient du verbe djokhar
culture jouer donc son nom ça veut dire
bienvenue dans le jeu c'est un nom
prédestiné pour une heure pour une
actrice
et pourtant vous avez commencé par la
danse vous étiez petit rat petit rat à
marseille à l'académie roland petit
exact vouliez être étoiles est en fait
vous serez comédienne parce qu'à 13 ans
et demi dont vous avez été casté sur la
plage vous étiez en train d'acheter une
barbe à papa avec votre maman c'est vrai
un geste est déjà lourd monde voilà
et vous avez été castée pour baie des
anges voilà ensuite j'ai eu voleurs de
vie avec emmanuelle béart et sandrine
bonnaire puis pas de scandale le
libertin daguillon qu'est ce que j'ai
préféré que vous me citiez pas à bout
lui en voulait non j en veux pas mais
non pas ça fait partie de l'expérience
hammam oui ça m'a beaucoup appris ici
vous avez pas dit que vous seriez à poil
dans le film quoi voilà c'est ça il
m'avait caché certaines choses
ensuite il ya eu vivante un film
excellent c'est ça commence comme la
boum et puis ça se termine très crade
quand même hein ah ouais ça c'est crade
la boudeuse cambouis et aujourd'hui un
film s'appelle il a dit ça de ziad ou
herry sortie le 26 janvier qui est
adapté d'un best seller signé chimot
publié dans 12 pays
quand même quand même énorme vous voulez
que je fasse le pitch baïda où vous le
faites
allez-y mais son la fin alors ah ouais
alors je fais pas la fin alors si
l'histoire de l'île aïchi mot deux ados
elle et lui ouvre son coeur en lui
promettant son corps et elle dit tout et
lui dit rien n'y pige pas quoi ll est
très fantasque comme ça et lui il est
très premier degré
très poétique ça va bien avec la bande
annonce qui va suivre je suis sûr c'est
vrai ses bagages il me plaît beaucoup
je m'attends c'est la bonne nouvelle de
la semaine c'est fout de ta gueule pas
du tout je vous dirais sensible en fait
je vous pouvez rajouter une couche
non ça commence première rencontre avec
le mec à lui dit tu veux voir ma chatte
éléments mal répond moi choses surtout
par thierry je peux choisir entre ta
chatte et libérer la palestine je
choisis ta chatte c'est quand même
vachement bien c'est pas des
palestiniens que ça fait rigoler 1 et à
lorient une autre scène aussi quand elle
est sur le solex laquelle mais sans
[ __ ] contre la selle et bien explique
que c est très agréable
c'est très agréable et l après le bronze
sur solex ans mais c'est vrai c'est
énorme ce film c'est du nu ça dépendra
du solex événements mais bon ça va
relancer les ventes de 6 à mon avis non
mais c'est très politique en même temps
c'est fini jeanjean parle j'en parle en
parle de mal mais j'en parle très gens
parlent très bêtement oui c'est vrai je
ne pouvais pas ah non non non vous êtes
celui qui en parle le mieux de tous les
journalistes
[Musique]
la seule chose que tu peux faire
maintenant c'est regarde ta caméra et 10
magnéto serge si j'en peux plus c'est
pas possible ici
[Musique]
j'ai avec toi j'ai prêté avec 100 avec
les avait tous sans visage dis moi tu
manges je te dérange que je te parle moi
je sais jamais ce que tu attends de -10
là quand je suis ça je pense à toi je me
prends en pensant à toi
[ __ ] tu m'as tu vas pas que je t'aime
[Musique]
voilà lille a10 à masi aguerris sortie
le 26 janvier avec vahina giocante et
notre invité ce soir
alors quand il lui dit mais pourquoi tu
parle toujours de ça elle lui dit mais
de quoi tu veux qu'on parle et ça ça me
bats c'est bien je trouve
c'est vrai qu'il ya pas beaucoup de
femmes comme ça qu'ils assument une part
fantasque sans tabou aucun fallait pas
beaucoup de tabous mais en même temps
c'est frais c'est pas crade qua non
c'est parce qu'il ya une certaine il ya
une certaine innocence en fait il ya une
certaine fraîcheur
de par leur jeune âge en fait une espèce
d'initiation comme ça la sexualité à
l'érotisme à presque vous vous rejoignez
personnellement les revendications de
villa sur la liberté la féminité la
sexualité
oui mais voilà je crois que l'émission
peut s'arrêter en fait toujours des
voies non membres oui oui sur certaines
choses disons que j'en parle moins parce
que c'est ce qui en parlent le plus qui
en mangent le moins donc il faut éviter
d'en parler trop pour savourer un peu de
recul de 3 15 heures
alors comme ça on en parlait la première
fois que vous venez dans tout le monde
en parle
vahina avec grand moment oui grand maman
moi aussi j'ai une grande montée tu es
passé toute la semaine
c'est vrai alors à faire une telle une
première fois premier coup de foudre
premier coup de foudre ce soir au
premier baiser c'était un baiser
papillon à ckoi baisser papillon avec
les yeux ouais ah oui tu sais faire le
baiser papillon et je sais faire le
baiser papillon le baiser esquimaux et
le baiser ventouses je sais comment le
baiser vente aux riches mais face à
gontaud d'un savoir faire métier états
clients mais faites moi confiance
d'accord je vous fais confiance
inquiétez pas on reste un peu sur sa
faim
l'intitulé faisait rêver pire encore la
joue c'est pour ça des taux réduit alors
on continue premier rapport sexuel
premier rapport sexuel
moi c'est tard je crois que 14 15 ans -
à cet arrêt oui c'est super ça rassure
bien les pères de famille
j'aime si quelqu un jour une carte
présence tu veux d'un coup ça me vrai
oui parce que j'ai trois enfants il
préfère te dire tout de suite moi je
sais je
premier tournage marie baie des anges 14
au premier cachet premier succès on va
régler ça on va arrêter c'est une perdue
ou alors en voiture et un raconte moi je
dormais l'interview luc ferland rallume
sert alors comme si la première fois qu
on se voit on va faire l'interview
rendez vous
[Musique]
sava ina très bon vous vous sentez bien
là ah oui oui très très bien vraiment
vous l'a un peu de musique non ça va
vous voulez que je danse c'est que j'ai
une très belle musique
[Applaudissements]
quelque chose de plus
[Musique]
[ __ ]
non
[Musique]
c'est bien
oh
hahaha
bravo bon
je vienne moi je suis mariée mais toi tu
dois être dans un état non moi je trouve
ça dégueulasse que ta copie quand luc
ferry danse et une coupe au montage au
casa sports et lucas très bien danser
aussi sonore il a dénoncé marina c'est
bien toute nue ça dépend des contacts
salata pas trop chaud là j'ai pas bien
plus frais j'ai un peu frais ya la clim
en fait tu veux qu'on l'enlève
c'est vrai mais comme m guînes les
gonzesses et déshabille pas cet âge est
né dans le film de parler de sexe comme
ça aussi crûment mais pas du tout pas du
tout pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut presque
on aurait des tabous comme ça je pense
en fait le vrai challenge était de ne
pas tomber dans une vulgarité d'arriver
à être être naturel sincère c'est comme
c'est comme les petits enfants il parle
de choses qui comprennent pas mais il
parle avec tellement de tellement de
naturel que tout passe fraîcheur oui ça
te plait dire des mots comme ça excitant
un peu mais ça c'est pareil ça dépend
des comptes et ça dépend avec qui sait
comment tu pourrais me dire un truc pour
moi ah bah pour vous et avait laissé la
voulait laisser tranquille semblant de
rien parce que je suis un curieux j'ai
envie d'entendre quand même perturbé je
sais que je vois ça va t'aider tu sais
que je vois ça a été les effectifs
étaient tellement été au courant quoi
mais ça je m'en fous alors ça c'est pas
un critère away ah bon tu tu aimerais
avoir un pygmalion mec
j'aimerais bien être le pygmalion de
quelqu'un bon d'accord j'aimerais que
cette émission dure tout le temps moi
c'est quoi ton parfum mon sérieux tu le
sens d'ici oiseaux c'est seynois à noah
ça sent bon
c'est excitant c'est tout faire seul
manila quotidien son parfum guillaume
dans sérieux non c'est pas sous préfet
inquiète religieux on t'a déjà proposé
d'être la femme de la vie de quelqu'un
dans sérieux oui un masaï m'a demandé en
mariage
ouais mais bon fabriquer sa cabale ans
kaka d'éléphant et tout ça et boire du
lait mélangé à du sang tu sais que les
magistrats gut s à moi si je suis une
machine guerrière
c'était a plu non ça m'a pas pu mais je
crois que c'est important les
expériences nouvelles c'est important
quand on est acteur en tout cas de se
nourrir d'un maximum d'expérience tout à
fait quel genre d'homme tu aimes
justement puisqu'on parle d'expérience
qu'un jour d'hommes les hommes très
autonome très indépendant très
très vieux des émissions qui ont des
studios c'est que j'avais vu pas mal des
gonzesses sur le plateau mettez une des
mieux quand même là tu peux pas rester
avec un vêtement l'asturien la semaine
prochaine
tu veux tu veux en venir la semaine
prochaine tu vas même le stand après si
tu veux ah bah si tu veux te fais pas ce
modèle est ce que tu es du genre à dire
oui facilement bah ça tu me proposes un
petit pétard oui si tu me proposes les
non non non mais si tu oui ça surprend
couru cinq ans que tu me proposes
d'accord il ya des choses en amour que
t'as pas encore fait parce que des
choses on aimerait beaucoup en bas
beaucoup heureusement heureusement tu es
amoureuse en ce moment non non non mais
je veux dire de en ce moment là alors
oui alors oui non mais là c'est là c'est
très
c'est très personnel c'est moi non mais
on oublierait presque qu'il ya 150
personnes en tout 150 millions de
personnes 150 minutes
[Musique]
oui
laurent une petite carte pour
mademoiselle vahina giocante quoi c'est
quoi ces laquelle vous avez cotisé avec
thierry ardisson
le tuer
c'est extraordinaire parce que je là
j'en ai gagné deux de dîner avec un
vaisseau là j'en ai gagné un troisième
là j'en ai gagné 1,14
[Musique]
voilà
il
m
leila turckheim t il pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu